so i guess for animators it's just like
watching anime is just like study
material isn't it
yeah for for most of the animators uh
now
one of my senpai he said i don't watch
anime now i'm
watching uh live movies and if i watch
anime i'm
watching uh animation of honda of or
inuisa
oh i think it's maybe the the best
animators in japan
right uh kind of to see where the
benchmark yeah
wow um you know sun's nickname is
the machine the machine
or what has inoy sun worked on uh you
know he's uh most of the directors of uh
manitoba crows are uh basically like
like the like the vip of that
or he's a you have a gengashu gingka
do you know what is gingka genghis or
the key poses a sure
of a uh archive archive it's it's like
an architecture
and a lot of if when it's in osan
every animator's because it's you know
sn he's uh
he's the man yeah wow it's so cool yeah
so you have some animators who are
very very talented and they are like a
sushi or sound of trigger uh nakamura
attack of bones
those names are very they have
put their touch in animation industry
that now
it's like it's like the kind of
animators where like even if you're not
exactly like a sakura guitar you can
just be like
that's a sushio yeah yeah yeah nowadays
whatever um
it's a very famous in young animators so
you have
like a music using a lot of
impact streams yeah um i did notice that
there's a lot of more impact frames like
impact frames is you know in the fight
scene
where it has like the kind of negative
of the image where it's like
you have you have the fight animation
and then sometimes it will just like
go into like the black and white
negative of it for like a few frames
that's
i'm pretty sure he started that trend
right yeah said i think he was one of
the first and
you know he's very famous because of his
utapong and it's a daybreaker uh
with the cube form yeah so you've you've
definitely seen some of his fights he
did a lot of
a lot of like the my hero academia
fights every shot
you say on my academy holy [ __ ] it's him
yeah okay yeah it's like it's like
versus back again
yeah like like when the ground explodes
then it's like blocks of yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah that's cool yeah when
it explodes it's like square blocks and
yeah he's now very famous of because he
puts his touch and so
most of uh every young animators he
imitate him learn from his animation
that's great and
yeah i guess like you know you probably
plan to do like more stuff right but
like
i guess like what's like one anime that
you've looked at or like one creator
that you looked at and being like
i wish i worked on that is it is that
like an anime where you just like the
animation like all the story was just
like so cool and you think like
man i wish i had like worked on that um
i don't know if in fact
it's difficult to put just one right but
for example i would like if i had the
occasion i would like to work
but now it's finished but the last
evangelion film i would like to work on
oh yeah
but um uh yeah it's a in fact
there is a it depends on of my schedule
if it's possible if i if i have the
level or not
because i if for evangelion things
they're only just
very very very few animate i'm using
very
very the most strong essentials in japan
okay because it's evangelion
so uh i think most of us
was working on does it hurt when you
have to deny like a job that you really
wanted to do because of your
yes yes i have so much denied some
proposal
some good stuff still don't announce
one framework oh [ __ ] my life